drunken horse is not only a great idea
for a country song but it's also a crime
and I am drunk driving
now the police in California arrested a
person on suspicion of driving Under the
Influence after riding a horse through
traffic police said that the horseback
rider was Galloping through traffic and
refused to pull the horse over this led
to a brief Chase which ended when the
allegedly inebriated writer simply gave
up California law prohibits drunk
writing California vehicle code section
21050 states that people riding an
animal on state roadways are subject to
all of the duties applicable to the
driver of a vehicle except those
Provisions which by their very nature
can have no application that means you
can't drink and ride if you are above
the legal blood alcohol limit of 0.08
percent so if this is the anonymous
writer's first DUI they face
imprisonment of up to six months at a
maximum fine of one thousand dollars and
when a reporter asks why the long face
he replied I'm a horse and my rider just
got pulled over for drunk driving